when you talk about confirmation bias I
wonder your opinion on sort of the
confirmation bias that surrounds the
question of Science and God so on the
one side you have folks like Sam Harris
or Richard Dawkins who suggest that
science has conclusively disproved the
existence of God that science absolutely
Cuts against the existence of a greater
being with a plan for the universe and
then on the other side you have folks
like Stephen Meyer who say no no when
you look at the science what you see is
God's signature in the cell and DNA you
see sort of clues that God has left
behind as to the organization of nature
in a particular way that speaks of an
intelligence Beyond mere Evolution for
example do you think that science Cuts
in favor or against God or do you think
that science really doesn't have much to
say on the issue I think I think the
latter and I view myself as having a
unique role in that I can sort of troll
The Atheist and I control the theists in
the sense of I think if you believe in
God if you claim to be a believer there
may be no closer window into the mind of
God than to study science it's the most
primitive distilled facts about nature
that may reveal in the case of some
people who believe in things like
intelligent design Etc that it may
reveal a window into God and on the
other hand if you uh you know if you're
so simplistic that you would reject or
claim that the that the Bible the Old
Testament however you want to say it
that that was a science book and
therefore you can refute it I always
like to use this analogy I looked up and
you're a sports fans you'll appreciate
this I looked up
um that the top 25 most famous NBA stars
and number one is Amari Stoudemire so
he's uh he's a convert I think to uh to
to Judaism but but nevertheless much
appreciated and number 25 and there's
like the off Shades and there's some
wonderful NBA players on this list and
then you get to the bottom and there's a
picture and it's an image not found like
there aren't that many great Jewish
basketball Stars just in history and I
said well how many total NBA stars have
there been in in total there's about a
thousand uh or about twenty five
thousand so that means that's about a
one in every one thousand players was a
Jewish player now imagine you pick up a
book and it says the history of the NBA
and it's a thousand pages long and one
page is about all the non-jews and so
forth and the rest is all about Jews in
the NBA you'd say this is not really
like I shouldn't judge this book by its
cover and the the Torah as you know
probably the Old Testament has about 35
000 total verses in it and 35 if I'm
generous would have to do something with
creation Evolution maybe if you're if
you're really willing to stretch the
same ratio 35 out of 35
000 and and so it's obviously not meant
to be read as a science book and this is
you know kind of I would say I adopt the
non-overlapping magisteria argument of
Stephen J Gould that these are two
different things Torah or Bible whatever
means wisdom science in Greek means
knowledge and so they're very different
things you know Wikipedia has a lot of
knowledge it doesn't have any wisdom
thank you for tuning in to the Daily
wire one of the fastest growing
conservative media outlets in the
country if you enjoyed this video be
sure to give it a like And subscribe to
our YouTube channel so you don't miss
out on any of our content